Here's the simplified expression. Great work if you got it correct. We can
divide 10 and 15 by 5, so I get 2 3rds in the front. Then I notice that I'll
have 3 more g's in my numerator than in my denominator. So g cubed in the
numerator. Finally, I'll have 3 more h's in my denominator than I would in my
numerator. So I'll have an h cubed, or h to the 3rd, down below. But remember I
said there's always more than one way to think about this. We can simplify our
fraction in the front, just like from before, so we'll have 2 3rds. Then we'll
have g to the 7 minus 4 here, we follow that with h to the 5 minus 8, 7 minus 4
makes 3, and 5 minus 8 is negative 3. G to the 3rd, has a positive exponent, so
we make sure we list it in the numerator. H to the negative 3 has a negative
exponent, so we know that moves to the denominator, and we change the sign to
make it positive. Think about the two ways to do this problem, and choose the
best that works for you.